الفنان الكبير ادوار بنرحب بيك على
العربيه كلمني على اخر اعمالك
ثلاث اعمال فنيه ان شاء الله
مختلفه باعمل مسرح وباعمل سينما وباعمل
دراما رمضان ان شاء الله
انتاج الاستاذ احمد الابياري والسي سينما
استاذ احمد فهمي
الاستاذ الكبيره سميه الخشاب ان شاء الله
هنعرض على نصف ديسمبر اللي جاي
وبعد المسرحيه سنه 1942
كان بكل نجوم الفن كانوا بيروحوا علشان
اللي عايز يغني او يمثل كان كان كازينو
بديعه هو المنبع كان الناس كلها بتروح
اسماعيل ياسين بقى وفريد الاطرش وعبد
الوهاب وكثير كانوا بيروحوا لكازينو بديعه
همم عمل استعراضي همم كوميدي دراما وجبه
وجبه هتبقى دسمه للناس
وكوميديا ودراما ان شاء الله مجهود قوي
يعني معمول في المسرحيه دي ان شاء الله
هيعجب الناس
[موسيقى]
والعملين الاخرين ان شاء الله باعمل فيلم
الميثاق مع الاستاذ رؤوف عبد العزيز وهو
فيلم رعب ان شاء الله
ده هيبقى معي الاستاذ فتحي عبد الوهاب
الاستاذه دينا فؤاد ان شاء الله هتشوفوا
عمل حلو جدا جدا
يعني مش هاقدر اقول طبعا تفاصيل عن
الفيلم الا انه ح- اا وفيلم واقعي يعني
فيلم الناس هتشوف حاجات بتحصل كانت بتحصل
فعلا
فهتلاقيهم مش مش فيلم خيالي تلاقي الناس
حاجه قريبه يعني
وباعمل ان شاء الله مسلسل جناب العمده مع
الفنانه الجميله روبي همم انتاج الاستاذ
ريمون بالمقار والاستاذ محمد محمود عبد
العزيز وهو تاليف الاستاذ ابراهيم عيسى
استاذ عادل القديم وان شاء الله هتشوفوني
في رمضان
القادم ان شاء الله
بيعمل مسرحيه
ايوه همم
ففي عوده للمسرح وان شاء الله نفسي المسرح
يرجع زي زمان كنا بنشوف عادل امام وسمير
غانم وهمم وسيد زيان ومحمد نجم كنا كنا
كنا بنشوف مسرح قوي
فاتمنى فعلا رجوع المسرح الفتره اللي جايه
يبقى فعلا عوده جامده جدا
واين نحن من السينما للشعر
زمان قوي ما اتعملتش في مصر بسبب تكلفه
يعني اكيد عشان اعمل عمل استعراضي للسينما
هيكلف كثير قوي قوي
انا انا هبقى ميليو ميديو انا هابقى
مليونير